salut aujourd'hui je vais vous parler
et vu
de demain le véhicule du sud se
souvent quand on pense aux véhicules du
futur
il ya des bonnes chances que ce soit ce
genre d'image là qui vous passe par la
tête
vous avez remarqué que je suis allé
puiser ses images dans des oeuvres de
science fiction notamment parce que la
culture populaire
ben c'est un reflet de qui on est en
tant que société vous avez aussi
sûrement remarqué que ces taudis
variantes de voiture pourquoi parce que
la voiture est solidement implanté dans
notre conscience collective
en fait en seulement 100 ans la voiture
est devenue de facto le moyen de
transport personnel avec le ton utilisé
en milieu urbain au delà de son côté
pratique la voiture c'est aussi devenu
un espèce de symboles de succès c'est
comme un élément de plus vers l'atteinte
du mythique rêve américain
pour d'autres c'est même une extension
de sa personnalité ce qui fait que c'est
vraiment difficile de s'en départir
pour répondre à l'adoption exponentielle
de ce moyen de transport
il a fallu qu'on adapte nos villes en
conséquence on a commencé à voir des
villes apparaître sans trottoir comme si
notre principal moyen de locomotion nos
jambes s'était rendu désuet
on a vu la démocratisation du béton de
l'asphalt comme principaux matériaux qui
viennent tant pis si notre décor urbain
en oubliant que du béton de l'asphalté
froid siguiri puis on a vu apparaître un
autre problème au fil du temps qu'on
connaît tous la congestion aux états
unis en amérique du nord
on estime qu'en octobre un automobiliste
par année va dépenser 800 $ en moyenne à
être immobile dans le trafic on parle de
dépenses en essence on parle de perte de
temps aussi parlants d'immobilité les
voitures passent 95 % de leur temps à
être immobile à être stationnés qu'est
ce que ça fait ça ben ça fait que l'on
réserve dans les grandes villes du monde
jusqu'à 50% de la superficie totale pour
des voitures
on parle de rue l'autoroute mais de
stationnement également on a donc vu un
urbanisme au service de la voiture au
lieu d'un urbanisme évolué au service de
l'être humain qui habitent dans les
villes
vous imaginez que toutes ces voitures là
ben ça crée un autre problème
sacré de la pollution les voitures
émettent du co2 en grâce qui notamment
responsables du smog et du réchauffement
climatique
tous les scientifiques s'entendent pour
dire qu'on est presque rendu au point de
non-retour part pas au changement
climatique puisque c'est aujourd'hui il
est temps d'agir les voitures sont
responsables pour un cinquième de tous
les gaz à effet de serre vous pouvez
vous imaginer que respirer cet art leurs
pensées pas forcément bon pour la santé
en fait dans les villes les plus
polluées du monde quand il du smig
on constate que c'est pire que l'effet
du smig est pire que la cigarette en
fait puis a non seulement le problème de
pollution mais la voiture ça fait aussi
que ont fais plus d'exercices
on se déplace plus en amérique du nord
en costard qu'une personne sur deux fait
pas assez d'exercice de base
c'est-à-dire marché faire les fameux 10
milles par jour
vous m'excuserez de dépeindre un
portrait un peu glauque de la situation
mais heureusement face à des problèmes
comme ça l'être humain est toujours bon
pour puiser dans son ingéniosité pour
trouver des solutions
puis de plus en plus seul sur le pen
passe par la technologie dans le domaine
de la mobilité urbaine ont assez
justement à une révolution dans le
domaine du transport
c'est la voiture électrique la voiture
électrique est alimenté par une batterie
par de l'électricité puis elle a une
autonomie de plus en plus impressionnant
qui fait qu'on peut vraiment remplacer
sa voiture traditionnelle par celle ci
c'est pas juste une révolution
électrique
c'est également la voiture intelligente
qui s'en vient c'est une voiture qui est
dotée d'ordinateurs hyper puissants qui
font en sorte que la voiture bain et
puisqu'on dit elle même
je pourrais même être écrasés dans mon
salon sorti mon téléphone comment d'une
voiture
plus tard m attendre devant ma porte de
ma maison je propose qu'on regarde un
petit peu les problématiques que j'ai
évoqué plus tôt pour voir comment la
voiture électrique
comment la voiture intelligente vais y
répondre ben au niveau d'urbanisme
si pas mal la même chose une voiture
électrique par la même empreinte qu'une
voiture traditionnelle puis demande des
infrastructures qui sont autant courtes
eur puis à écrire le même stress et
infrastructures qui coûte cher au niveau
de la pollution de l'environnement
ben là à une bonne nouvelle les voitures
électrique c zéro émission sauf que
l'électricité faut bien qu'elle vienne
de quelque part puis le problème c'est
que dans les pays industrialisés la
plupart des pays industrialisés
il ya beaucoup de réseaux énergétiques
qui en fait roule encore à des
combustibles fossiles sacrés vous l'avez
devenir des gaz à effet de serre fait
c'est quand même surprenant problèmes
qu'ils ont mais tailleur rose da c'est
beau on y pense pas c'est un autre
problème
enfin pas de côté finalement au niveau
de la santé ben c'est statu quo en fait
c'était même pire parce que au lieu
d'avoir à marcher pour aller chercher ma
voiture ben c'est elle qui vient à ma
rencontre
la voiture électrique la voiture
intelligente c'est pas le véhicule qui
va régler nos problèmes de mobilité
urbaine en fait un véhicule qui vieux de
200 ans de 200 ans qui veut régler notre
problème de mobilité urbaine
c'est le vélo le vélo c'est les
véhicules que le meilleur rendement
énergétique en dépensant la même énergie
que je prends pour marcher je peux aller
5 fois plus vite je peux me déplacer
cinq fois plus loin en milieu urbain un
dépassement sur deux est de moins de 10
kg mais pour vous donner une des 10 km à
vélo ça à peu près une demi heure dans
certain que quand il du trafic en fait
je me rends même plus rapidement à vélo
qu'une voiture qui vont être prises dans
traffic donc pour ces déplacements
l'heure c'est le vélo qui leur est
considérée pour la plupart des
déplacements pour l'autre des placements
sûrs d'eux celui de plus de 10 km
le vélo peut quand même être d'une
utilité parce qu'en fait ils pourraient
s'insérer dans une intermodalité des
moyens de transport ça veut dire que je
pourrais prendre mon vélo
si j'habite par exemple sur la rive sud
je peux me rendre jusqu'à une station de
train prendre le train en au
centre-ville loin bixi puis aller à mon
travail puis juste pour être clair ici
le problème c'est pas la voiture en tant
que telle la voiture après un d'utilité
puis ça je le dément pas le problème
c'est que on remet pas en question notre
choix de véhicules automatiques nous dit
on va prendre la voiture c'est sûr que
des fois on fois les chéquiers sauf que
je vais pas m'acheter une étagère chez
qui à chaque jour si on regarde on prend
le vélo puis on analyse à nouveau les
problèmes que j'ai voté plus tôt
c'est presque absurde à quel point le
vélo règle tous nos problèmes
c'est un peu comme une infopub future
gare puis le produire est comme tout et
prendre espère donc dans l'univers le
sait quoi larnack là dedans bien ici on
n'a pas en fait je pense qu'une image
vaut mille mots
ici on a 200 voitures sur la route ici
on a 200 vélos le poids que les vélos
font sur les infrastructures ainsi
considérablement réduit on a bien
portants les infrastructures on n'a pas
autant besoin de les maintenir qu'avec
des voitures qui sont lourdes
au niveau de la pollution d'écologie ben
je pense que c'est assez évident les
vélos n'émettent pas de co2 ça coûte
aussi beaucoup moins cher en vélo c'est
beaucoup moins polluant n'est pas de
matériaux de piles qui ment des métaux
rares l'extraction de métaux rares qui
est très polluant en fait
puis finalement bien au niveau de la
santé
non seulement je me sens bien quand
j'arrive au travail mais faire une demi
heure de vélo par jour je brûle 304 et
je fais d'une pierre deux coups je pense
pas que je vous apprends grand chose en
vous en vous exposant les bienfaits du
vélo mais pourtant nos villes
ressemblent pas on n'a pas de masse de
cyclistes qui se promènent en ville pour
aller au travail
comment ça se fait quand ça se fait que
sachant tous les bienfaits tous les
effets pervers de la voiture
mais on change pas nos habitudes ben il
ya des chercheurs qui sont pour faire
une question
puis on demandait carrément à des
citadins ont dit pourquoi pas le vélo
plus souvent puis en fait on se rend
compte que toutes tes réponses évoqué
ramène à un point
c'est les infrastructures déficientes
bon
on mentionne notamment banque faire du
vélo c'est dangereux on mentionne jazz
c'est trop loin aller en vélo à mon
travail je peux passer le vélo à faire
du vélo l'hiver c'est trop dangereux
sauf qu'en fait c'est toute épreuve que
la voiture peut vivre aussi
si je voulais sur l'autoroute puis que
dans mon changement de voyage en tgv qui
était dans ma voix de gauche
ça c'est quand même pendant dangereux
mais c'est une chose à vélo connaît un
camion qui arrive effectivement c'est
dangereux
en hiver c'est dangereux faire du vélo
connaît de la glace dans voiture aussi
puis est ce qu'on fait on déneige les
rues on a développé des infrastructures
pour vraiment améliorer la conduite
automobile
pourquoi on peut pas le faire pour le
vélo la bonne nouvelle c'est que des
changements d'infrastructure bah c'est
pas si complexe a fait ici même au
québec ont investi des millions de
dollars pour faire des nouvelles
autoroutes va faire de nouvelles pistes
cyclables ça coûte une fraction de ce
coup là puis l'autre bonne nouvelle
c'est qu'enfin aussi que ça marche
développer des infrastructures pour
vélos ainsi que ça encourage la pratique
du vélo parce que y'a d'autres biens
qu'ils ont fait ça c'est une autoroute
cyclistes à copenhague semaine
les cyclistes du point a au point b de
la façon la plus rapide possible parce
qu'à copenhague on s'est dit les moyens
de transport qui polluent le moins qui
sont meilleurs pour la santé nos
citoyens on va s'arranger pour que les
infrastructures soient les meilleurs
pour eux pour les voitures mais au
contraire on va rendre ça plus compliqué
il y en a peut-être qui habite dans
plateau qui se reconnaissent un petit
peu ici
flexion sait que faire des
infrastructures pour vélo finalement
c'est pas si compliqué ça ça se fait et
en plus ça marche mais peut-être que
c'est pas un problème d'infrastructures
mais c'est plus un problème de culture
qu'on a
en amérique du nord face aux vélos on a
grandi avec la voiture
la voiture est sexy non seulement c'est
la voiture nous rend sexy
justement si si je prends un costard
blanc qui m'accostent sur une aston
martin ben je vais pouvoir séduire plein
de femmes fatales
nous on a la même silhouette aimerait
juste le char lundi au fil du temps la
voiture il veut lui avec des nouveaux
déserts vraiment stylée des gadgets qui
nous font vibrer mes parents ont acheté
une voiture n'est pas longtemps puis bon
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est mes parents
sont à la retraite qui ont été vraiment
raisonnable toute leur vie faites les
110 ans web et on prend un gros char qui
comprend toutes les options c'est toutes
les options ils savent pas de quoi ils
ont pris puis je les conduis je tripe
elle s'était coup je me sentais comme un
gamin là dedans je faisais la voiture
mais reconnaissez que j'avais la clé
dans ma poche fréquence des bars
automatiquement il ya un bouton pour
partir le moteur il ya des écrans
tactiles sont comme plus coloré que ma
télé dans noces à londres et je peux
passer mais la glace avec une commande
vocale
c'est vraiment une si on est d'accord
mais c'est quand même vraiment couvre
six organs côté du vélo bain
c'est pas cool faire du vélo c'est pas
sexy
le personnage de steve bauer défaites
zéro dans ce film là ça fait 40 ans qui
est vierge
si on regarde l'évolution du vélo dans
les créations du 100 dernières années
bien on se rend compte que depuis 50 ans
le vélo a pas changé vraiment en fait
d'un côté ça témoigne un peu de la
solidité de ce designer mais d'un autre
pièce à contribuer un peu à l'image
désuète du vélo puis ce qui est
paradoxal c'est que même les compagnies
qui offrent des produits pour cyclistes
pour améliorer la vie des cyclistes ben
on taxer les produits qui sortent tout
droit des années 90 moi en tant que
cycliste urbain j'ai pas eu but de
mettre un truc qui ressemble un black de
lui sur mon vélo personnellement pitié
s'il vient me merlet recommence il qu'on
nous cheap
ben je vais automobilistes qui arrivent
à destination il enlève pas ses phares
avant pourquoi les cyclistes ou encore
le faire pourquoi le cycle et c'est
encore traités comme des citoyens de
deuxième classe
considérant tous les biais fait du vélo
bah c'est là que 3 n'est associé puis
moi même on a voulu faire la différence
on s'est dit pourquoi le vélo pourrait
pas connaître une révolution
technologique
tout comme la voiture et c'est pour ça
qu'on écrit ce malgré l'eau saumâtre et
l'eau ça se connecte à monter fun ça
s'installe sur le guidon de n'importe
quel vélo ça transforme le vélo en vélo
intelligent en offrant en pleine
fonctions avancées aux cyclistes
donc c'est un gps pour naviguer les
cyclistes en ville c'est une lumière qui
s'allume la nuit puisque c'est
automatiquement la fin de mon trajet
cinq systèmes d'armes qui va protéger
mon vélo contre le vol un des plus
grands fléaux qui affiche tous les
cyclistes puis c'est aussi comme un fait
dit un fitness tracker qu'on dit ça va
se faire le suivi de toutes mes données
cycliste les calories que je brûle la
distance que je fais la classe moyenne
ecce terra je peux même me mettre des
objectifs puis le cercle va montrer ma
progression vers ces objectifs le
contrairement aux produits que j'ai
montré un peu plus tôt ce matériau ça
reste sur le vélo ça fait partie
intégrante du vélo s'est attaché avec le
système antivol
c'est ça qui fait en sorte que j'ai même
pas besoin d'appuyer sur un bouton les
produits mdd détecte automatiquement
value mais la menace il fait noir
activer le système d'armes si je m'en
vais bref j'ai même pas besoin d'y
penser en tant que cycliste
vous avez remarqué aussi que l'interface
est composée seulement dans le cercle
lumineux mais ça c'est parce que en
milieu urbain qu'on fait du vélo ben
faut avoir les yeux sur la route faut se
concentrer sur le trafic on peut pas se
permettre d'avoir un espèce
d'ordinateurs avec des noms de rues des
chiffres complexe c'est tout simplement
dangereux puis au delà de ça c'est aussi
qu' on voulait garder un espèce de
minimalisme qui est liée aux vélos
espèce de pureté de et puis au
delà de ça ben c'est aussi qu'avoir un
cercle qui se transforme qui changent de
couleur sur un didon ben c'est quand
même pas mal cool
quand de créer ce match où je peux pas
dire qu'on avait l'ambition de changer
la mobilité urbaine opérer un changement
de culture ça prend du temps ça se passe
pas juste avec un quad technologique
par contre si ça peut crédibiliser le
vélo auprès de quelqu'un qui verrait ses
petits halo lumineux s'allume et c'est
déjà ça de gagné d'après sabin tout peut
se passer
peut-être même que dans un de ses
prochains films au lieu d'être au volant
d'une aston martin
magic band il sera à vélo merci côté
gabriel alberola
[Applaudissements]